the change goes in the octopus for a few
reasons first off we don't want to mess
up the data that we already have and
second of all we don't actually need to
change the data itself it's just the way
we're getting the data from the model to
the view now why not the view why not
put this in the view well first of all
the view shouldn't pull things directly
from the model remember they shouldn't
talk directly so as long as we're going
through the octopus it makes sense to
give the view only what it needs now
that being said technically you could
put this functionality in the view but
for my model view octopus example I'm
going to leave it in the octopus the
octopus is where I want all of the real
smarts to live in this organizational
paradigm whereas the model and the view
themselves are relatively simple now if
you use other organizational libraries
they all have different opinions about
where exactly different functionality
should live but in all of those cases
they're consistent and well thought out
so for envio we're going to keep all of
the smart functionality and the
filtering and everything in the octopus